thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we're talking
about
what was the most intense moment where
in most situations say you're in you're
in a relate of your relationship or in a
relationship
where breakup was imminent
where you accepted something that maybe
your younger self would have clowned on
your ass for accepting
wait I totally like started thinking
about Dubai what's the what was you just
said do you think about peanut hookers
no so what was the most intense moment
where in in most situations breakup is
about to happen
but you accepted something where your
younger self would have clowned on your
ass for accepting because you wanted to
save your relationship
like something simpy anything whatever
anything anything your younger self
would have clowned on because yeah your
young violated your younger values
whatever it is all that if my younger
self saw me now
he would have thought I was super
homosexual I mean at the brink of
breaking up though like where you were
like
you know where you did something oh no I
look at my younger self like he was the
he was the homosexual
there you go get him at the brink of I
think we're trying to do the whole
sentence but you're not you don't have
an older son
you don't have an older selfie yet in
this scenario it's just every
relationship that's really important if
you're about to break up yeah you only
want to stay together and so you kind of
you know how like David so has a story
how he dropped his knees and grabbed
their ankles it was like like that like
his younger self would clown on him for
that yeah did you have a thing like that
Yeah I broke oh we I broke uh broke up
with my first girlfriend that we like
had a lot of virginity times together
too and then like
um we had long conversations after and
then she was like she did the whole like
oh uh I I think uh we can still be
friends thing so in my head I thought
like oh that means like it's a break
yeah and then been there and then so but
then she told me she still loved me and
stuff like that and I'm like how you
make it confusing just [__]
just chop it off don't like make it
confusing like that I don't know what
that means especially when you're like
17 you don't know what that like gray
area love thing is right so I was like I
ran out of words to tell you so on her
voicemail I just started like playing r
b songs so she knows how I felt because
it expressed better than what I can say
which song
Brian McKnight
so you guys got back
for sure
[Music]
[__] Boys to Men okay the river the
rivers run dry one
kid you were a teenager would have been
like this guy's a [__] loser dude
that's a whack move
D that was me at the time and I looked
back like a month later and called
myself gay yeah nice
as you should well handled yeah the r b
thing that's nice yeah because that's
like I don't even think do do kids now
or like teens now go to that I feel like
they probably send a Spotify playlist oh
yeah like what song are you trying to
tell me
recently didn't Boise they still tour
yeah
but do like is that thing a thing still
you know like like it's so common back
then to like use songs as like a I can't
express myself but this will now they
send voice memos dude probably oh oh no
I don't know probably not or Snapchats
or some [__] damn definitely Snapchats
Spotify playlist yeah probably Spotify
playlist like I made this playlist for
you I'm thinking of you they probably do
something like that yeah man that's sad
well yeah being on the brink of breaking
up does drive you to do some pretty
stupid [__] yeah for sure
especially when you're a teenager yeah
or your first love or your first love
like yeah like over using your phone to
call them or text them oh God picking up
like that is the most cringiest thing
and you look back you're like oh my God
just shut up shut up stop calling and
stop saying leave her alone leave yeah
yeah just keep digging your hole Yeah
Yeah Yeah
girl that I was like talking to in high
school and I like thought I loved her
and then she you know she she met she
was over aim and she was like you know
like I don't think we should see each
other anymore
I remember thinking like I still love
you you know something and then she was
like cool this is over oh thanks
it's all good baby like this would be
great and in my head I was like oh it's
gonna be a break but it was like the way
I reacted to it was like I was so
[__] like sad I didn't want to eat
were you crying while typing no because
at the time I was like I was like fine I
was like okay he cried in this [__] I
cried in the shower that would probably
be one where I was like oh you have all
your clothes on too dude I did the thing
where you slide
and your dad's like quit jacking off in
there yeah
and I'm like all right as well he
already said
[Laughter]
those little Chinese those little Asian
stools did you get like the little kids
tools yeah yeah we had one in our shower
and I was like sitting on it like the
little four-legged ones in the corners
it was like a little like bear on it or
whatever
oh God [__] dude that's definitely one
where I was like I felt that one for
sure I did that mistake of like hey like
how are you how are things so I've been
thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just
just oh we can fix the situation yeah
yeah I came up with some solutions yeah
yeah yeah so like I was tripping like
I'll be so different this time I think I
was um my first girlfriend that I ever
had when I was 16. we um this was like I
think when we finally broke up like a
year and a half later or some [__]
we would I [__] did this it's not
this is not that remarkable but like we
were we were in front of my house in
Downey like breaking up and you know it
takes forever when you don't know what
you're doing and uh I think like at one
point like we're standing on the uh the
curb and then at one point I just like
was like what's the [__] point man
and I backed up where I'm like in
traffic and I'm like waiting for a car
to come to like I'm not gonna I'm gonna
dive out of the way yeah yeah yeah but I
wanted her to like to like grab me but
she was just like looking at me crying
and I was like what are we [__] doing
man it's like and then a card game this
is like middle of the night and the car
actually came [__] and he's like
obviously not going that fast because
see me and I'm just standing here
looking at her and he like stops in
front of me with his lights on and he's
like hey what the [__] going on
she just like pulls me
you guys do this thing where you guys
put your foreheads together like yeah
exactly like I would obviously and then
we still broke up anyway yeah you know
but that's a good moment though that is
so hilarious stupid like why the [__]
would you when you're that young dude
yeah did you see these exact situations
going on in the world when you're
driving around you're like what a
[__] loser and it's all from movies
dude yeah the other day I heard this
couple from across the street in the
same alley where the another fight was
breaking up uh there's a couple a young
couple they're probably like maybe
College they were just like yelling at
each other I told you to stop [__]
you're the girl was like you have a
girlfriend and you're you're trying to
talk to me like this and they're crying
and yelling at each other in the in the
[__] alley and I'm like who the [__]
is making all this noise and then Tiff
is like she's like go check out who it
is and I go look and I go oh babe you
gotta hear this
I'll walk I'm in my underwear too I walk
all the way outside I'm like what
this is crazy like other couple fights
are pretty entertaining oh for sure but
it's not you yeah when you're observing
of course
because you get to see like them like
double down on their emotions yeah and
just like take it to the next level in
the in the argument
like oh somebody snapped
it is sad to see when like sometimes you
catch a girl on the phone and you know
that's kind of what's happening to her
and she's just crying those are sad yeah
those are pretty sad
fights did you you I feel like Colleen
you never had something like no that's
what I'm saying I was that person as a
teenager like cry let me text it a whole
paragraph like write a note
um so you were sipping yeah you were
like like for breakups or something like
that like even if
I mean maybe I mean now I know so I'm a
little bit biased to my own train of
thinking but as a teenager like you
think that's like the end of your world
you like you think like this is real so
you know you end up being dramatic about
it mine was when the girl too are you
kidding like
mine was when it was early 20s it's the
girl that we mutually
I know today's video is brought to you
by Warby Parker so do you have this
problem where sometimes you buy glasses
and you get it and you pun her face and
it's like is this for a baby and then
sometimes you buy glasses and you come
home what is this for a giant and you're
like you know what I wish there was a
program out there where I could try it
at home and don't feel like I am
committed to buying it I could just try
it and then return it well guess what
Warby Parker got you covered oh my
prayers have been answered look at this
wow I got me a cool pair of Warby Parker
glasses and what's awesome is sometimes
when you're online shopping you really
don't know what you're gonna get because
physically what shows up
but you already purchased it and it's
like such a hassle to return these
stuffs but with Warby Parker you can
choose five of whatever you want to try
on they send it over to you and you get
to go from the mirror and be like this
one I'm gonna get the ladies with this
one I'm gonna go to job interviews with
this one oh it looks horrible I'm not
gonna use that one but I settled on
these it makes me feel like I'm a Blues
musician without playing the blues but I
look cool so I decided this one I'm
going to keep and for the ones that you
don't want they'll give you a free
shipping label you could return it no
strings attached baby but the quality
solid and I like what I got because
Warby Parker offers you everything you
need for happier eyes
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
even eye exams and you can shop with
them online or in stores I've been
seeing them around glasses start at 95
including the prescription lenses try
our Warby Parker's free home try on
program order five pairs of glasses to
try on at home for free there's no
obligation to buy it ships free and
includes a prepaid return shipping label
try five pairs of glasses at home for
free at warbyparker.com off the Record
and I remember uh when it was over I
felt so bad I was like oh there's
there's not enough context like the
phone is holding me back and so insane
yeah so I ended up all my feelings out
um and I went to I was like what's
what's sentimental oh I need to get a
leather backed notebook so let's go buy
like a notebook that was like
you know the ribbon that you can like
yeah
College line paper it needs to be
something where it's like cool this is a
Keepsake you know yeah yeah she's gonna
cherish this and then I was like and I
remember
um
I remember also finding a pen I was like
what's your favorite color green
[Laughter]
so I remember writing all my feelings
out quill and [__] and then writing out
like the life that um that I imagined we
would have had oh my God that hit me
good then I gave it to her and then she
actually read it in front of me
but then it still didn't work out your
reaction
oh what was her immediate reaction when
she read it you know where she read it
you know the garage you know the the 619
yeah
there's these like trees but my mom
likes to collecting three steps I don't
know why
true we just had tree stuff free stuff
to sit on she likes like wood and [__]
okay so she said they were like ghetto
ass tree stumps that you would use for
log fire oh so they're not like they're
like this big redwoods they're like this
big and if you don't carefully sit down
and get a splitter yes
so there's like one that's there I'm
seeing trees tree stumps so you invited
her over to read it yeah so I can like
because I knew if I just talked to her I
would lose track of my train of thought
so I wanted to ride it she reads it so
she and then that way like we can kind
of talk through it didn't work out what
did she actually say was she like it's
still not enough you know what was cool
about her she
um was really positive and she like
it felt like she really empathized on
how I felt but she just wasn't in the
right place to be with me right because
she still has the guilt of but she
didn't make me feel like I was a [__]
creep you know so that was cool she was
very nice yeah that's a sweetheart move
but then later on you think you're like
why do you treat every person like
that's gonna be your last person you
know uh sure like as you get older
you're like every person that's like
like you're gonna meet so many people in
the world like why do you treat it like
this is the last person you're ever
gonna meet like why did I even imagine
this crazy life yeah movie The Notebook
with with her I think when you're
younger you thirst so hard you can't
control it and their new experiences
though too yeah like when something's so
new to you you think man like this is
all that's all this is it right until
you start learning a little bit more I
have one of your bracelets that you gave
me at home so it's real we have to get
married
everything's so meaningful because it's
the first time exactly yeah that's true
and then it's it's literally a drug like
the way that you feel so intensely in
that teenage level like it's just the
first time for everything it's so it's
like your first hit of weed you're like
oh my God and then you're eating that
hamburger on weed for the first time oh
my God and you had this hamburger before
but not on weed you know yeah yeah yeah
and I feel like the same thing with just
the flirting and the in the romance and
all the highs that you're getting in in
those teenage years it's like
it's hard to follow that up older and I
think it's because like
it's not the very first and then your
your emotions and hormones are crazy
yeah so I feel like yeah you can't
regulate it dude when I was 18 and I
broke up with my girl I had a community
college dance final which was like it
was its uh Cypress College you know the
Cypress College theater was like a kind
of decent theater so we had to do our
final all the people in dance classes or
dance uh programs got to like perform at
the theater and like friends or family
whatever would go yeah and then uh we
were already broken up but she came
anyway to like kind of like patch it up
or something so she's in the audience
and I saw her and I started dancing oh
dude you're ripping it sorry you're
tearing it up but it's like so stupid
because it's like I'm doing a [__]
College dance show yeah but you proved
to her that you're like he's dancing and
your sneaker's all squeaking but also
I'm I'm I'm absolutely no one at this
point either so it like but I thought
it's funny that at your most nobody you
think you're the most somebody oh yeah
you know what I mean do you think she's
staring at you the whole time that's the
best thing or I think that I'm doing
something cool at all yeah
but yeah we didn't uh I I left right
after that so I never talked to her or
saw her again yeah are you sure showed
her I sure did you [__] served her
right you know though looking back at
all the relationships that I desperately
wanted to keep like because because you
just oh the pain hurts from breaking up
and you just don't think you'll fight
another I'm like so [__] glad that I
it didn't work out and it you didn't
stay for real right you see them and
they're just completely different people
who they are now I was with a cheating
ass [__] and I was fine with it she was
cheating on you yeah she cheated on me
and you wanted to keep her I didn't care
I was like yo I love her I was like man
I'm so into this [__] anyway and then I
was like how old were you this was like
my second serious relationship so I was
like mid-20s got it and I was like dude
this and she like admitted to cheating
on me how long were you guys together we
were together for like three years oh so
you already kind of committed yeah I was
I was hella committed yeah yeah and then
she admits that and then I had to say
something kind died in me for sure like
something like that trust was just gone
but I just I just thought I loved her so
much that I was like you know I was like
I'll push we're gonna push through yeah
we're gonna work hard yeah and she
didn't even because because of what she
did it wasn't like she was like [__]
and sucking and getting dumped in and
[__] because if that was the case I
probably couldn't have made it happen
it's getting dumb she like they like
just did like a little kiss I mean that
she'd love
well she was a she was pretty
forthcoming
about what had occurred maybe that's
still like truly cover up
[Laughter]
[Music]
if I'm honest he won't think that
there's more yeah okay
preemptive yeah everything there because
you never really know right right it's
like we just had a little kiss and then
you you rewind to what actually happened
and she was going kissing the dick
exactly
turned out better anyways I did yeah but
that's the thing is I I already because
like I remember I remember talking to
Nikki and she she told me she was like I
remember you always like used to talk
about this chick like you guys were like
set you're gonna get married and all
that [__] and then she's like one the
one the one time that you were like she
was like how's it going with that and
then you're like
um you think you're gonna get married
and [__] and I was like nah nah and then
she was like really and after that that
kind of also she knew you and you knew
me during this yeah and then um she was
like oh [__] Steve we might not be
[__] getting married this [__] after
all and then but that was when I had I
had found out that she had cheated so it
just completely changed the way that I
saw my relationship how long afterwards
when you found out where you guys it's
two months and we were done oh yeah
dude and then how long after that were
you with Nikki I was [__] Nikki youth
in seven days
so romantic
been [__] her ever since like oh so
you're not getting married great come
with me you should you should have said
I was I've been stepping on her head
since I have been yeah yep well I
started stepping on her head three years
ago okay so it's a new thing oh yeah I
started double stepping we got to keep
the relationship back yeah it's funny
too how like you know like you're
thankful that you didn't stay with all
these like different people in your life
but then sometimes you look back and
you're like ew I was with that but it's
like also you just changed too yeah they
are all they all turned out whack yeah
it's like you just kind of also maybe
you were a little whack then too yup
yeah or your waxes
oh thank God right yeah it's probably
Mutual in many ways and they're right
we're all right as a kid or like even me
like the Romeo phase of like I love love
and all this [__]
um I would have definitely taken a big
shot at me for staying with and cheating
us cheating [__] yeah and that's that
was I definitely looked back on yeah
Jesus you would have sacrificed a good
chunk of your own self-esteem exactly
there's girls that I felt like were
gonna be married and have kids and I
can't wait and then like I was
devastated when it didn't work out and
then now I'm just like damn dude I
wouldn't be able to have this life if I
chose that one and I thought that one
was gonna be so much more better but you
just don't know because it's my
imagination of what I want it's not the
truth and I think that's where guys
really sabotage or just young people
sabotage their own mind is like you are
so sure of the outcomes because you just
want to relieve yourself from the
current pain that you're in so you you
just have a imagination of what the
outcome will be with the partner that
doesn't even want you back
that's the [__] weird [__] your true
feelings right now true yeah thanks Joe
why you just brought up old memories
dude and I'm [__] pissed about it but
you're you're in a better situation now
yeah but you know but the memory of that
point just think of someone not wanting
me dude is just [__] soul crushing
hey but there's times when you didn't
want others too right so it goes kind of
both ways I don't think he has oh wait
never mind he doesn't have the same
experience though I don't really have
those experiences dude he only has one
that didn't want him and one that maybe
doesn't
we still don't know
like she said yes but every day I'm like
are you sure are you sure about that
yeah you sure about that
most people have experience of going
back and forth so you do have an
incredible success rate though if you
think about the amount of relationships
you've been in oh dude you're killing
all of us killing everybody yeah he has
a 50 success rate he's been in two and
one worked out and at the end of the day
it's all about dedication and just
mindset and information
yeah so if you guys want to buy my
course on relationships
exactly
[Music]
foreign